when I started getting into DMT where I
was having encounters with light beings
what did you think the light beings
worked with acid and mushrooms you don't
typically at least I never had visuals
with the DMT
this was like full-on like that you're
seeing a whole world just crack open in
front of you what would they tell you
these three beings come in my room and
another one came in it was dragging my
body and they told me if you don't stop
doing heroin this is you
[Music]
as Society continues to get crazier and
crazier one Theory I have to explain
some of the craziness
is that everybody is on drugs
everybody is on prescription drugs
psychiatric drugs the legalization of
marijuana and specifically
hallucinogenic drugs hallucinogenic drug
use has increased dramatically in recent
years LSD use is up something like 400
percent over the last 20 or so years
psychedelics more broadly up
significantly and for
all of my sins and degeneracy that I've
engaged in in my whole life drugs has
never really been one of them so I
decided to bring on an expert on drug
use and how to get off of drug use that
would be Josh Zatkoff Josh how you doing
thank you for coming on the show yeah
thank you for having me before we
started I said Josh how would you like
me to introduce you and you said I don't
know Josh
it's you now have really turned your
life around you uh are an evangelist you
but you you've had a rough past
homelessness jail time
and drugs correct yeah
so the reason I want to find out about
all this is not so that I can scold
people and say just say no like Nancy
Reagan I guess I do kind of want to do
that but but I want to know more about
it I want to know why people are so
interested in drugs and specifically in
these psychedelic drugs
yeah I mean it's definitely an
interesting topic and I think it's
because
people people are all in a search for
something you know we're all searching
for the more to life I think for me uh
personally it started off with curiosity
you know for me I remember watch being
like 11 12 and seeing the the comedy
movies and you know they're smoking weed
in there and stuff like that and so you
see that and you're like I want to try
that it's being glorified the cool
people are doing it um
and so for me it started out just like
that and then once I was a curious child
so once I had encountered somebody that
had access to that it was it was natural
for me to to want to try it and so when
I did uh
it it gave me a new Taste of reality
like a different reality you know it
felt like it was the the missing piece
to my life that I you know I'm saying
because when I was younger I started
feeling uh that desolation in my mind or
that you know that that weight of
Oppression kind of coming on me and I
didn't even know what it was it was you
know I mean I started to feel depressed
and stuff before I started to feel
depressed after you started using drugs
or before you started using no before
yeah and I had but I didn't have like
the language for it I didn't know that I
was depressed I just thought I was
feeling you know sad or something
but it seemed to take like a darker turn
as far as like I don't feel like all my
other friends are dealing with this you
know that's kind of how it started to
feel and um so it didn't just feel like
you know 13 year olds or angsty and
you're saying
are you saying now in hindsight even
what I was dealing with was in fact
heavier or just that it felt heavier
looking back I know it was heavier you
know because so like when I like as a
young kid even like seven eight I would
like scratch my face so like I had anger
issues like I had all these self-harm so
you know like that stuff was there is a
little seven eight-year-old you know and
my mom has a has um
has little you know writings or whatever
Diaries she kept for me
um and one of the one of her entries was
saying how you know she she came home
from the babysitters and I was chasing
with a butcher knife you know like at
seven eight years old and and I think I
was she she's like you were just being
silly but yeah yeah you know and um so
it's like that but that stuff looking
back was like it was it was there it was
blatantly in front of everybody's face
but like how do you deal with that I
definitely did didn't know it wasn't
normal though because I'm not living
with other kids you know what I mean
it's not like I had a bad childhood I
had great parents great family all that
were your parents married yeah yeah and
so what do you attribute that to was it
mental illness was it a spiritual
condition was it an accident no it's
definitely Mental Illness but I believe
mental illness most of it a lot of it is
spiritual that's that's my take on it I
think a lot of it's spiritual and so
when I look because it's always
producing something negative for the
most part people that deal with mental
illnesses whatever variety of it it
always you know produces something
negative it's never something you know
good or you know like that does
something good for the world it Causes
Chaos and stuff and so when I smoked
weed for the first time
oh it was like everything fit together
and was like oh this is what I this is
what I needed and so it was just
interesting like right off the bat I was
like oh this is this is what I want to
do in my life and and I tried to you
know that's that's kind of that was my
first it was it was a romance it was you
know it was like love at first sight or
something you know and um and so I
became obsessed with marijuana because
it made me feel like I was a better
version of myself why marijuana instead
of booze I guess I like I like tobacco
and I like alcohol and I thankfully I
haven't
for all my problems that that has not
been won I've never really felt addicted
to to those kinds of things but I like
them you know I mean I like a cigar and
I like a drink whereas I don't really
like the the old Devil's lettuce which
I've smoked on occasion and yeah that
never really grabbed me but it did grab
you yeah no I think it's a it might just
be a personal preference I didn't like
alcohol because I didn't like how it
tasted I think the first time I drank I
was maybe like 13 and I remember I had a
group of friends and
it was just an app it tasted nasty and
then I was like man you know smoking
it's quick it's like you you know within
a couple seconds but drink I'm like I'm
sitting here and drink all this stuff
and to feel you know because I just
wanted to feel drunk yeah um and so I
didn't I didn't like it because I didn't
ever liked feeling like sloppy and like
so obvious uh weed made me feel like it
was a more
nonchalant kind of thing so I think
that's why I was just a personal
preference so so far we've covered all
the drugs that I have any familiarity
with
when I was a kid I told you drugs didn't
really attract me at all with one
exception I was curious about
LSD and mushrooms and people now today
are always talking about Ayahuasca and
all these like the psychedelics
interested me and I never did them I
kind of had a little bit of a fear of
them because I was told when you do it
your brain is never the same it kind of
rewires you and I thought well I don't
know I kind of rely on my brain so I
don't know that I want to rewire it but
I was
curious about us what could I see if I
took these drugs so when did you
graduate to those kinds of drugs um
so when I got into high school about 14
you know I got I saw the movie uh the
doors Jim Morrison with Val Kilmer and
man I never felt like I related to
somebody so much like like when I was
watching him I felt like I was watching
the person I wanted to be or something
in that movie uh so much of me connected
with it
and so he was doing peyote and acid and
stuff in the movie and so at some point
in high school I had a friend get have
acid
and I did it and it wasn't like I didn't
I didn't take enough I don't think
nothing really happened but I felt kind
of just different but nothing really
happened and then a few months later uh
or yeah like probably the next year I
think it was like 10 my sophomore year
high school
I had mushrooms and so the mushrooms I
was sitting in somebody's car and
it was like a it was like weed all over
again it was just a whole new reality
I'm saying you know and I spent like
three hours you know back in the day it
was like the CD players had the little
pictures on them and like you could pop
them in and out and I was for three
hours I was just sitting there staring
at that you know like that like it just
got me entrenched into this like this
new reality and I'm like look up I'm
with my friend and it's like dude we've
been doing this for four hours having
the time of our life it was just it was
just so intense I
I had this experience of just feeling
like there was uh like the universe was
alive like I felt connected to the
things that were around me I felt like I
was connected to life
um in a different way and I started
thinking different I got more I guess
deep in my thought I started just kind
of becoming more philosophical and and
you know in my approach to just how I
was viewing things in my perspective and
so it was like how
how is it different in in that
I go through my daily life I I feel that
the world is teeming with life I mean I
I feel connected all the things you're
describing I feel that in my ordinary
day-to-day life you you describe the
sense of going deeper or thinking more
philosophically and I don't so I don't
have experience of the mushrooms but I
think I've I read a book and I think
more philosophically where I look at a
work of art and I
so how what was different about the
all of that on the mushrooms
I don't know if I could say it was more
of it slowed everything down and made me
more like it was like oh look at this
water like and you notice every little
bubble it just like made you so
appreciative of the moment pulled me
into the moment in such a way where I
appreciate things I never appreciated
before and then there was this feeling
of just Joy like I couldn't stop
laughing I had you know I mean I was
laughing the whole time and I had the
time in my life
um
and so it just at that point I was
hooked like it was like I can't wait to
ever do this again
um and then what happened was I actually
went to a rehab not like a month after
that I went away for for a year in a
rehab and in that rehab I got into
Buddhism
and so when I started to read about
Buddhism and and taoism and stuff it
started to meditate I started to notice
that the the ideology behind it was
lining up with the ideology I was kind
of having on the mushrooms
so it was like this you know there was
this dynamic between them that started
to kind of cross many such cases by the
way my friends who have gotten into
shrooms and acid and stuff they have
gone down that sort of Buddhist Taoist
Eastern mystical route so you you end up
in the rehab was it a family member or
something sent you there or yeah yeah my
parents because my mom you know she on
her side of the family there was a lot
of addiction my dad saw the family had
alcoholism so they were just being good
parents you know they see their kids
falling down that hole um so they were
just trying to help you know right and
but the thing is is I was you know I was
15. and when we were 15 you think you
know everything you don't want help in
my mind I'm like I'm just smoking weed
um you know my I try to ecstasy pill or
something a couple of things but in my
mind everyone else I was with was doing
the same stuff so I didn't think it was
you know absurd or anything
um and so when I went to the rehab I had
gotten into to Buddhism
um
and while I was there I think because I
didn't have a family and because I
didn't have I'm just with a bunch of
kids from all over the country that I
don't know
um the place got shut down for child
abuse so it's like I'm with you know
wacko people leading it um
and I think I felt like I didn't I I
only had myself it was like the first
time in my life it was like you're on
your own kind of thing you know that's
how it felt was like all you have is
yourself to to rely on and so Buddhism
kind of uh it it taught me I guess how
to kind of be strong Within Myself And
it taught me the power of like what was
within me and it taught you know what I
mean and so I I just took to it and I
got addicted to it um you know because I
was on a ADHD medicine at the time and
so that you know gives you hyper focus
and all that and uh so I just that's all
there was nothing else to do I mean I'm
stuck in this place for a year
um and so that's all I did I started
meditating and reading books and yeah
and you you found that there was a
commonality in the perspective on the
world did you find there was a common
effect you know did you get the same
sort of high by meditating in this
Buddhist manner
um
I wouldn't say to that extreme or to
that extent
um
but I started meditating and I started
having
um moments where I would get something
that would remind me of it and I'll give
you an example like there would be
moments where I'd feel like I would
start kind of vibrating or something or
um
I would just feel like this this Divine
connection that reminded me of when I
was on the mushroom so it was like these
moments of it but the difference was
like I felt like I had to work for it so
with the mushrooms that you take this
and you stay there you rest there but
with the Buddhism it was like you're
doing this stuff I'm meditating I'm you
know to get to that place and then try
to stay there
um so what you're describing
sounds generally Pleasant I don't know
that it sounds like an ultimate uh
Triumph for Joy or Victory but at least
it sounds kind of pleasant you're just
vibing you know feeling with the
universe man and so
How does it go wrong oh man well so
that's kind of that's I mean that's a
long story this we're talking like a
decade of of Journey to find that out um
so after the rehab when I came home
I got my first legal trouble
um so when I got in my first legal
trouble I was 16 I got put on probation
um I wouldn't stop smoking weed I I you
know I'm actually friends with my
probation officer to this day you know
on social media and stuff and so she was
really cool towards me but I kept
smoking weed and I told her I said I'm
not gonna stop you know I said if you
unlock me I've been locked me and so I
was going in and out of juvie like you
know I would fail my urine test and then
I'd go for like 30 days two weeks
whatever and then eventually I said you
know what I gotta find something else
and so uh one day I was on house arrest
with my friend and he asked me he had a
painkiller
and uh he he asked me if I wanted to try
it with him me and him had never done it
together before so I did the painkiller
and um it was just it was like the same
thing again it was like this this
feeling I never had the best feeling I
ever had in my life me and him looked at
each other and we're like do you feel
that and um
and so that began basically within six
months I was shooting up heroin so whoa
so at that point
um psychedelics were always there as
like a here and there thing
um there was something I just enjoyed
um but then at one point I guess
probably
Maybe
10 years into it it's I'm trying to like
do the math in my head of like time
frames around 19 like 20
um psychedelics were
they were something that I did when I
was I needed heroin to function
basically right so like the heroin was
that was my addiction but the
psychedelics at that point they started
off in high school was like a party
thing it's like you go to the party you
have fun you laugh but I knew the
spiritual element was there and so once
I got uh to the place of like liking
Buddhism and stuff like that I started
taking them to kind of jump into the the
spiritual aspect of it so I would take
them and so I had nothing but good
experiences you know like I had nothing
but positive things happening as far as
I would have this like new profound
wisdom would hit me I'd have this
understanding of being connected being
one uh all of us loving each other it
was like that's the secret to life uh
love each other you know um is there any
was there any wisdom perhaps that is the
wisdom but is
is there anything you remember now
looking back on it ah yes here was a bit
of wisdom that I gleaned on one of these
trips that I wouldn't have known
otherwise is there anything you can
point to and say ah that piece of wisdom
or no was it just kind of a feeling of
wisdom no I think it was just more of
just a different mindset it was like
just a different level of Consciousness
that when I was in that place everything
made sense so it's like it was all and
it's like the funny thing about
hallucinogens is like uh a lot of the
stuff you forget it's like you're here
and then it like leaves you and that's
why people keep oh you know I need to go
do another Retreat I mean because it's
like I know it was great and I know I
learned a lot yeah I just don't remember
anything I learned yeah and you take
some of it with you you'll take like one
or two things and then the rest is
forgotten and um so that's what it was
it was like
um like in an example was like I always
would walk away with this feeling like I
need to be a better person like it would
it would crush my my ego and Crush my my
pride in the moments you'd get you know
I mean and I would I'd be like man I'm
really a bad son I'm I'm really you know
I mean like I'm a bad brother you know
I'm saying like I would have these these
real like I guess reflective moments and
so because of that I'm thinking this
must be a good thing because it's it's
bringing I guess uh sobriety to my
thinking in a way you know I mean it's
it's making me see things different
whereas other drugs they feed that
selfishness it's like that heroin you
don't care about anybody but on
psychedelics I'd be like oh I need to be
more mindful of other people stuff like
bro I've been around people who have
been on coke and they're the most
annoying people on planet Earth they
never shut up they're talking about the
most boring things ever for some reason
they always are trying to get you to do
Coke I've been offered cocaine so many
times in my life and I've never done it
it's not not something that's interested
me but I thought isn't this expensive
like why are you trying to Peddle your
expensive drug on me why are you talking
about your work assignment from last
Thursday nobody cares just like they're
babbling it anyway anyway I I could see
that distinction between a drug that
kind of pulls you out of yourself much
as Buddhism does Buddhism is essentially
a denial of the self and and a drug that
pulls you really into yourself but so
what you're describing
other than your life completely falling
apart while you're doing it yeah other
than that little detail it sounds like
the hallucinogens are fine
yeah it seemed that way and so I thought
they were the answer yeah so my whole
life goal was I just need to trip like I
wanted a perma-trip that was my goal you
hear these these horror stories there's
this story that goes around everyone
says I know this guy who thought he was
a cup of orange juice yeah right right
like everyone's heard this story and
somehow it's like their friend he thinks
he's a banana he peels himself off yeah
you know it's and I would I I honestly
at the time was I was jealous of that
like not not that outcome but the the
outcome of like I could stay in this
place because I like again I liked who I
was in that that state and so um it was
always like I just need to go trip one
more time
um collect the data and then remember it
and stay there and um and so the the
other thing was like so the there was
positive things when I started getting
into DMT where I was having encounters
with light beings you know what I mean
I'm having they're they're talking to me
they're telling me you need to stop
doing heroin or you're gonna die they're
guiding me in a positive way
but at the same time I'm getting more
into the occult I'm playing with Ouija
boards thinking it's a game I'm egging
on like the Ouija board move and I'm
telling it you know show yourself that
you know I'm egging it on I'm thinking
it's all a joke I think all this stuff
is a joke so you're playing with the
Ouija board
the Ouija board the idea is it's not
your hands moving the thing around but
it's
demons basically it's moving this all
right did it work
so
it's funny because in my first encounter
with the Ouija boards my mom used to
have them as a prop for Halloween no one
played with it it was just when
Halloween parties and she just had the
Ouija board there it would just be a
prop right and um I I think one of the
first times I remember using it and it
wasn't like I did this like hundreds of
times it was maybe a handful of times 70
times and it's the first time it worked
was I was at a friend's house I was I
think like eighth grade summer or
something ninth grade eighth grade
summer and there was a group of us at
this this girl's house and so it was a
group like me five or six was playing it
and it starts to move now you know
everyone's first reaction is is it you
is it you is it you everyone's not no I
swear no I promise no everyone's not I
know it's not me the thing starts to
move people start getting freaked out
and me again I'm I'm challenging this
stuff I think it's a joke yeah because
even though I think like oh it really is
moving on its own at this point now but
I'm like asking it stupid questions you
know like oh if you're real show your
face you know and stuff like that and so
it starts to move and people will start
getting freaked out so it was like me
and I think it was like two or three
other girls and another guy
they said and they they start saying one
of them said you have to ask it if you
can leave like I heard you know you
can't just or I'll leave the door door
open you have to ask if you're allowed
to leave so they say can I leave and it
goes yes can I leave yes and so next
thing I know it's just me and this one
girl and she says can I leave and it
says no
so she goes to trial and she's like can
I leave no and it goes no no and she
just freaked out and she just like she
just like ran off and I was sitting
there and just laughing and so it wasn't
you moving it and so you could say well
maybe it's this girl just wants to you
know spend more time with you yeah I'm
gonna move it to say no yeah but she
gets very freaked out and then she
leaves no it was genuine fear like she
was like oh my gosh I said no no she
just like freaked out and she left
so that was like the first time I saw
something come from
um and then years later I played it back
when I was getting really into the DMT
uh I just I had one and I was with one
of my friends and this guy was you know
he was a very stoic kind of guy he
wasn't a type of guy to like get scared
easily like me and him used to you know
do all types of crazy stuff together he
wasn't the the type of guy to for one to
to play into it and to to get scared
about stuff like this it's just me and
him you know we're and we start playing
and like I said I lived on the that
Battlefield and so we started asking and
things that starts moving I don't even
need to ask I knew it wasn't him he knew
it wasn't me he starts moving so we're
asking him multiple questions
and he's I started asking him like well
when am I gonna die what and it gives me
it gives me a number and it says from
overdose says 37 from my overdose then
it's and then he asked it and it gave
him a number and it gave him uh it said
I think like heart failure or something
heart attack or something
to this day that friend is scared he'll
he called me literally like last year he
said he like he freaked out he I mean
that like and this is
2012 2013 I mean this he to this day
he's still afraid of that he still
thinks that's going to happen yeah of
course how old are you I'm 30. yeah are
you scared no no because I I think the
blood broke the curse so
but I think that it would have happened
I think that that was the intention I
think that was the plan for my life
maybe you know
um but he's I mean he still thinks that
like he's he called me actually like a
year ago or something he said dude I
only have a year left if that you know
like he thinks it's gonna happen right
because
demons can't read your mind demons are
not God demons are not omniscient or
anything like that
but they are pretty good observers of
behavior
and So based on the behavior that you
were exhibiting for a long time it may
have been a perfectly reasonable
inference to say oh yeah you'll die at
37 from a drug overdose yeah yeah 100 so
why are you doing because people tell me
this they say oh yeah I play with Ouija
boards and crystals and weird astrology
stuff but it was all just kind of silly
games and I think when I want to play a
silly game I play Monopoly what is it
about
what Drew you to the Ouija board and all
the occult stuff I think just us as
humans we're drawn to the taboo no I
think it's part of our nature we like
that mystery that that's why people like
horror movies and stuff and it's like
and your inhibitions are already a
little bit weakened because you're doing
all this other crazy yeah yeah I was
already I liked that that like kind of
that I like the Demonic type of stuff I
was drawn to the dark stuff not uh you
know not in the sense of hey you know
Devil with pitchfork and horns but the
the stuff that made people uncomfortable
I wanted to go into the water that
everyone else was like I don't know it's
a little crazy the secret yeah yeah and
so that was it was just something I did
with like friends I'd play the Ouija
board I started doing the psychics I
started you know I went into all that
because of Buddhism is already kind of
branched that's a I would say those are
branches of that it's like that whole
world kind of comes together
it's the same thinking and so I started
getting more into the the occult and so
what was crazy is when I was
um about 20 2012. I was doing a lot of
psychedelics I was doing a lot of heroin
I was in probably the worst place I had
ever one of the darkest places in my
life and so I had this moment of like
I'm having encounters with light beings
they're why am I not happy
why am I still stuck I can't stop doing
heroin I want to kill myself and I'm
have I'm thinking I'm enlightened I
would have a trip and for a week I'd be
the most enlightened I think I was
Gandhi for the next week I'm Gandhi
everybody and then a week later I want
to kill myself and so I'm starting to
connect these dots like this doesn't
make sense like why why am I having
these great experiences but I can't ever
bring back the the fruit or what I
thought was fruit I can't ever bring it
back to my life and I can't find the
power to overcome any of this my
obstacles what did you think the light
beings were did you think it was a
figment of your imagination you know
just a chemical product of the of the
drugs or did you think they were Angels
or something so with with acid and
mushrooms you don't typically at least I
never had visuals where like oh I'm
seeing this thing just pop up it's more
like the walls will melt everything's a
lot more vibrant
um
but you know you might you could see
something it starts to look like
something else I had time like my dog
turned dog turned green and his tongue
was longer stuff like that right like
but like you know like oh this is
reality dog yeah yeah yeah like it's
like I knew it was reality with the DMT
this was like full-on like that you're
seeing a whole world just crack open in
front of you it's like going to Mars or
something right like right now this room
you know just turns into you know
another realm right and it's like so I'm
experienced so I knew I was
hallucinating but I also knew 100 this
stuff is real whatever is in my room
right now these things are real and they
they would be light beings so they're
they're a human shape
but they are like um they were colors
one was one was purple one was orange
one was red it's like a flaming light
but in a human shaped body right so it's
like a silhouette and then um the thing
about them is that they would always
um speak peace like we're here to help
you we're you know calm down relax we
have your you know we have your back and
the thing that was interesting and I
didn't pick that up at the time but
looking back
it literally was like you know when
you're swimming in the ocean and you
feel like that there's something maybe
under you it's like you're enjoying the
waves it's fun but you're kind of like
oh there might be a shark that's how it
felt it's like I kind of don't trust you
guys but I don't have a reason not to
you look pretty you're giving me good
information
you're clothed as an angel of Light yeah
yeah and so that's that's kind of where
it was at but um it just never
and they gave you advice in the sense
that calm down it's okay what would they
tell you well they would so like the one
DMT experience I had I had these three
beings come in my room I freaked out I
started to try to get up off the bed but
there was a bigger one like so if I was
laying down
it was like his legs were 10 feet tall
so the other ones I see in front of me
dancing around the swirling this one was
10 like 10 feet tall legs I couldn't
even see the top of the the being but
his hands started going over me and if
you've seen Reiki they go like this like
they do he was doing Reiki hand
movements over me and he was telling me
telepathically relax we're here to help
you right and then a few minutes later
my door opened up by itself and another
one came in it was dragging my body so
I'm in my body I'm watching this my body
gets dragged into the room and they told
me if you don't stop doing heroin this
is you and and because I used to get
high in my bathroom and so I knew they
were saying like you're gonna overdose
in this bathroom if you don't stop and
so that's what I mean like they would
tell me like you need to be a better
person you know so what is that is it
seems to me
there's four options it could be your
subconscious you you knew even as you're
doing a bunch of dope you know that this
is bad for you it's going to kill you so
it's your subconscious telling you that
like in a dream say or they're demons
the cloth as angels of light as it says
in the Bible or they're angels
or they're just some weird chemical
hallucination totally random totally
unaccounted for totally meaningless
which to me seems like the most
ridiculous possibility of all
so which of the three is
so I think the interesting thing is that
if you talk to anybody that did
psychedelics
I think everybody would agree they're
all real it's it's like it's everybody
it's not just yourself it's not your
imagination your subconscious I think
there's times people think like your
subconscious can create stuff that isn't
really there
but those experiences are 100 and it's
another dimension it is the it's the
veil is removed and I think that's what
gets manipulated because of our
ignorance you know um and so uh and I'll
give you an example the first time I did
the mushrooms I started to climb up a
radio tower and then I got about 20 feet
up and I saw oh what am I doing I
shouldn't be climbing a tower right now
I started to climb down that inflicted a
thought of fear where I started for some
reason because I was in the woods I
started thinking about the Headless
Horseman and I'm like oh the hell this
Horseman's gonna get me I started to
hear I started to uh hear horse horses
come right so that was a a example of me
thinking something right and then it
kind of but I knew oh I'm just tripping
yeah you know like oh this isn't real
right now I went back in the car I was
fine because you hear that expression a
lot be like oh man that guy's tripping
over there yeah obviously where it comes
from is like you literally were tripping
and you were imagining something that
wasn't there yeah and I was imagining it
and I knew I was but this was different
than what was going on in your way
different but so then my but my question
is
it sounds like they're demons but
they're saying hey don't kill yourself
get off the heroin which seems like good
advice so then it seems like they're
angels right right so what is it that's
the that's the deception in it and so I
think uh Romans 6 talks about it says it
says you're either a slave to sin or
righteousness it says look at the fruit
of what's coming from this and so I
think that a lot of times we have to
look like what is the fruit that is
coming from this like the the fruit that
was coming from this was not good in any
sense for me even when they say get off
the heroin that's not good well I guess
because it didn't work because it didn't
there was no power there so it was it's
kind of like I I always use this
illustration of if I'm trying to kidnap
somebody I'm not going to say you know
hey I'm here to kill you kid like come
in the car it's like here's some candy
hey I want to get you down there here's
a hundred dollars so they don't if if
you look at like the the state of Satan
being the God of this world in a fallen
State fallen angels having uh you know
secret knowledge and you know what I
mean principalities and Powers Yeah and
all this stuff
they're not dumb you know and so they
can give you stuff that looks good you
know
right yeah right and well yeah we I
guess our imagination is just limited we
think oh those stupid little Devils
we're so much smarter than them yeah
no they're pure intelligence you know
they're probably probably more
intelligent than we are oh yeah in many
ways so
you're in the room you're surrounded by
demons basically and and you're saying
they're real you're you're
aware of the it's not just something
you're imagining and you see yourself
you see this vision of yourself dying
from heroin and okay then you wake up
from the trip
so so okay so I wouldn't but this you
this is before I haven't kind of got all
that this is this is when I'm around 20
years old I think around 2012 when this
happened I see this and I'm I think that
they are angels at the time they were
light they seemed loving they seem to
have my interest at heart so I did think
they were Angels at the time
um and afterwards I was like rocked for
I mean that that will really mess up
your your view of life for a while like
I I didn't even know how to look at life
the same anymore after that and um and
uh and I was then but then it's like oh
I gotta do it again I got to do I gotta
I gotta meet them again whatever it
takes right like and give me some more
poison so I can meet those angels yeah
and and you know and
um but here's what happened so about uh
a week or two after that
um at my house I'm sitting there I'm
depressed because I was going through a
breakup and I'm not getting the whole
story but long story short I'm sitting
there one night my best friend had died
the year before in a car accident on his
way to meet me so I felt bad about that
I was dealing good about that
um
my life is falling apart in front of my
face I just had a baby that's probably a
year and a half old at the time and I
was like everything had was so hopeless
and I'm sitting here doing spinning my
wheels trying to like connect to these
these Spirits Spirit realm and go to the
psychic go to getting Reiki done doing
all the stuff that I could think of
everything I think of and I remember one
night I just sat there and I had kind of
like surpassed you know what I mean
depression or anger or any emotion you
know I don't know if it's apathy or or
what so you were just uh despairing at
that point you weren't even angry you're
just so there's no hope it was just yeah
like that that Pink Floyd song
Comfortably Numb it's like it just just
nothing just you know and and so I I
basically said yeah I think I'm done I
was sitting on my back porch I was
drinking
and I said uh I'm done I said yeah I'm
not doing this anymore I walked in my
house and I got uh a microphone cord and
then I walked back outside and I had I
lived on a battle Oh you mean I'm done
like I'm done yeah I was dead seriously
I'm just done I don't I don't want to be
here anymore and I because you have to
think that this I mean my for years this
was always in the background but you
don't ever think you'll actually do it
it's kind of like I want to but I
wouldn't actually go through with that
um you know I mean I was cutting myself
I was I hated it I hated life I hated
myself and I didn't even know why I just
I just felt like I was just chained to
something that I didn't want to be a
part of
and it's like you're you're you're
sitting in the passenger seat of your
car and someone else is driving that's
how it felt for the last you know or the
previous few years or whatever and
um and so I said I'm done and and so
there I lived on a battlefield like a
actual Civil War battlefield right and
so that added a whole another element to
this like spooky stuff going on but
anyway nature is but art unknown to thee
yeah yeah
um and there was so there's the you know
the the fences it's like Civil War tied
up so I where I lived it was like a
cliff that was in my house and there was
a it was a cliff and then it was like a
uh there was a little small stream and
then it was like a little creek that
broke off and it was like a 20 foot
something draw like 20 22 feet drop and
Cliff and then like two feet of water
and so I tied it to the the Civil War
post and I tied around my neck and I
walked to the end I said I'm done and I
just stepped off and uh the second that
I felt the cord it tightened it pulled
and it caught I went as soon as it
caught me I was like oh no what'd you do
like this was a this was a mistake what
are you thinking but it was too late I
like I knew it I I really like did it
and so next thing I know
um uh it feels like in a dream state you
know when you're in a dream and you're
aware like a like a lucid dream it felt
like that but in the dream I had no
memory of what I did so in the dream I'm
just wondering like why can't I breathe
why am I cold why do I feel stuck I
didn't know I had no idea what's going
on
and so in the dream all of a sudden well
in that state I see um This little light
out of the corner of my eye and start
coming towards me it wasn't a big light
it was just like a little like they
grabbed your attention from this this
black void it started coming closer to
me and the next thing I know I felt
something loose my neck still not
knowing what it was just oh I can
breathe again in this dream and I I
grabbed and I got up and next I know I'm
popping my head up out the water
and it all hits me like
what just happened so I'm sitting there
like I mean I'm crawling up this hill
I'm so glad it's the middle of like
December middle winter time
I'm freezing cold I'm shivering I'm
crying because I realize what I did you
know I mean I go in the in my house I
have bruises all over my neck and my
neck's all purple
and I mean I was I was a mess and but
the thing that happened that night is
that I knew that there was something out
there after that like something saved me
and the craziest part was that I said oh
it came untied from the fence it
couldn't just be the cord Snapper it's
not right that's what I'm thinking I go
back out there it's still tied to the
fence
so it was a microphone cord it stretched
maybe double the length I guess because
of the the you know what it was it
stretched
whatever it was I knew something saved
me like if it didn't snap it didn't
unfurl no
so it it just it just stretched and it
was attached to both ends but even then
I was I could I was unconscious I
couldn't uh did it had it snapped where
it was tied around no it was it was it
was it was it was just loosed like I'm
I'm unconscious
just knowing that I couldn't breathe I
didn't know there was something on my
neck I was I was unconscious I went out
um I saw a light coming towards me and
when it got like maybe like 10 feet away
from me it just I just felt it Loose
just
and so I and then I popped up and so
then it hit me at that moment
I'm here for a reason
um something cares about me and
something is aware of me
and I have no idea what uh or or why
but now I gotta figure out what it is
you know and um and I wish I could say
like oh it's God and and everything
changed at that moment it didn't it got
way darker it got way worse
um because there was no there was no
language there was no understanding of
what it was it was just I'll never do
that again that was really you know that
was about all that I I had at that time
and so it was I'll never do that again
but I'll do all the other stuff I've
been doing yeah basically but not not
wanting to you know and that's that's
the worst thing about it you know drugs
it's like it starts out fun
and then you're a slave to it and you
can't stop and it's the most miserable
existence because you got you know
everyone's telling you just stop look at
what it's doing here look and you can't
well you make this great Point uh which
you're not the first to say it which is
that you're either a slave descent or a
slave to righteousness and the way that
people talk about freedom and liberty
today even on the right certainly on the
left but even on the right is really
shallow and incoherent because they'll
say is freedom is just being able to do
as much heroin as you want that's
Freedom baby you know if you want to do
heroin you have the right to go do
whatever you want and as you have just
attested
and now you become a slave to it and you
become a slave to it very very quickly
and it doesn't that's not an expression
of Freedom that robs you of your freedom
you know you're going to be a slave to
sin or righteousness you're going to be
a slave to Vice or virtue and uh so the
question is
then what is freedom what and it freedom
is obviously when you uh accept the
constraints of virtue and goodness and
then and Christ says you know my yoke is
easy and my burden is light follow me do
what I say but don't worry my yoke is
easy and my burden is light and the Yoke
and the burden of heroin
and all the and all the all the light
demons uh it's not light that's not
light at all yeah so you but you keep
going into it
because you say okay I'm not going to
kill myself anymore but I'm still
addicted to drugs I still have been
practicing I've been in cultivating
these habits for 20 years or whatever 15
years and so uh you're not just gonna
switch that off overnight or it would be
very difficult to do that yeah
so then what happens so basically I go
down this road for you know years
basically
um and I'll go to basically the next
couple years I'm just I'm getting worse
in my heroin addiction it's becoming you
know it it started out the first few
years it was kind of like uh the drugs
are always there I had the jobs that
would somewhat support it so it was like
comfortable yeah then it got real
uncomfortable then it got miserable you
know when I'm always sick I'm always my
whole day is like chasing that
and um so when I was 23 2014
uh I was going to school for massage
therapy I don't know how that was a
miracle in itself that I don't know how
I graduated the school but I get through
massage therapy school somehow right and
uh three days before I like get my
graduation certificate I already had
graduated but I'm waiting for the
certificate or whatever
um I basically get hit with a
distribution of heroin there was some
girl that I was uh you know kind of
friends with I had middleman something
to her she overdosed I called the police
or the ambulance to resuscitate her and
she you know she ends up Surviving but
she tells me so I get charged with a
distribution of heroin at that point I
had you know done a little two weeks 30
days in jail well this was like this was
a big serious offense right they're
trying to tell me she's dead and all
this stuff tell me I'm looking at a
murder charge all this crazy stuff I
knew I knew they were just saying that
but
anyways I end up getting the the
distribution so uh 2015 I get sentenced
to 18 months in jail and so in that
point I really smacked you know life
smacked me in the mouth and and really
sat me down to really because I have a
kid at this point
um you know it's there was no more
running and so at that point I got sat
down I was like man I need to change my
life it was the first time in my life
that I really wanted to change or not
that I did that I really wanted that was
really serious about change like all
right I'll really do what I need to do
and uh so in the jail I had ran into
actually old friend and um he had been
there for like five years at that point
and he he's talking about Jesus to me
I'm and I'm I'm looking at him I'm like
something's different about him because
I knew him from the streets you know I'm
like something is different about the
guy
unspeakable joy that dwells within him
you know yeah yeah so inevable yeah yeah
um and uh but he but he's talking about
Jesus I'm mad at him I get mad at him I
snapped on him and I said dude stop
talking about this Jesus
and um and then I left to another jail
and
uh but for some reason this was another
like one of those moments in life where
I have no idea why I don't even know
what happened just at some point I
started to think Jesus was my God no
even I didn't even really believe in him
I just was like you know what I tried
all the other gods maybe Jesus will be
my God yeah heroin didn't work yeah
Buddha thing didn't work
you know what I love about that is
everybody
wants everybody expects these kinds of
stories that would be in a Hallmark
movie or something and you know and this
was the this is the climax of act two
when I but the way you're telling it
it's like yeah and then I just realized
yeah now he's got yeah yeah I just
figured out yeah that was it yeah but
it's so obvious you know yeah but it was
weird because I didn't there was nothing
yeah I don't even think I believed that
yeah I think it was like I'll try this
one next it was I didn't believe that it
was God so it was an experiment yeah it
was an experience I didn't I did I just
would start talking about Jesus and
mention the Bible but I didn't seek him
or anything I just would and it was
crazy because when I got out I remember
I was like making music and and I'm like
I was listening like some of my old
music and I would shout out Jesus I had
no relationship with them whatsoever did
not know him at all but I'd be like yeah
Jesus whatever right and and then the
next line talk about something crazy
probably right but um
um so what happened though is after that
this is when everything started to
really change and and boil down to it
and so I get out in 2016.
I'm trying to get my life together I'm
trying to solve heroin but I'm still
going to the bars I'm still you know I'm
getting blackout drunk and and when
you're a heroinette that's really good
you're real proud of yourself you know
all I'm doing is drinking yeah so I'm
gonna get my prescription for my Xanax
I'm I'm doing good but I'm so I'm
blacking out all the time and um but I'm
going to church that was the one thing
that changed I started going to church
like uh you know two or three times a
month and nothing happened though but I
would go and it was like it was just for
me it was just a one day that I could be
someone else you know it's like I I
hated to have to be who I was and I just
wanted to like go and pretend to be
somebody else or like you know just feel
like I could get away from my life or
something it's just this Common Thread
from the beginning of the story through
this point which is
you're trying to escape an identity that
you don't like and and trying to escape
time and space right this this is
something that I I've heard from friends
of mine who have been addicted to drugs
and booze and stuff and then frankly
that I even I feel if I have a if I have
a drink at the bar after work which is
oh it's kind of like time slows down oh
I don't I'm so stressed I'm on this
tight schedule I'm ah but now time
uh all the constraints of that work all
that stuff
that's gone for right now and so you
know you're you're
finding that in all these different ways
and and one does find this at your you
know church on Sunday you go and if if
the Liturgy is
proper then it is different it's
supposed to be different from the world
you're in the world a lot of the time
and then the church is uh
a kingdom that is not of this world
right right yeah and that's what it was
it just was like something cool to do
that you know I did it by myself and and
so there's I met this girl that would
that would take me and
um and so I started doing that but again
nothing changed my life as far as like I
wasn't doing heroin and that was about
it you're doing everything else I was
doing you know I mean I'm still sleeping
around I'm still drinking I'm still
doing this and that and
um and uh I started getting more into
music and I was like all right I'm gonna
do music that's my what I'm gonna pursue
in life and
so I started doing that uh and then I'm
building my life back up I finally get
my my uh my license back after like not
having it for a few years I get a
restricted license I get a car and two
days after I get the car I wreck into a
fire truck get a DUI yeah I've had it
for two days you know
and uh and a fire truck pulled in front
of me I hit it there was no damage but
the cops come my friends with me he's
he's passed out in the passenger seats
they arrest both of us I get DUI I I get
out
um and you know I start trying to get
back up on my feet I get you know move
into a basement I was living with my dad
at the time and and my parents were
split up at this time they split when I
was like 17 so like so I'm living with
my dad at the time
and I'm trying to get my life together I
have a job I'm doing landscaping I'm you
know I'm working working to get on my
feet and um
and so I uh I have this stuff that I'm
building and then all of a sudden it was
like
and I and here's the thing about God is
that I you don't see him working a lot
of times in the moment it's when you
look back and so I didn't notice any of
this it was it was but all of a sudden I
started feeling bad about I was I was
prescribed Suboxone which is like to get
people off heroin and stuff and and I
would but I would shoot it up which
you're not supposed to do you know but
but when you're a heroin addict like if
something's water soluble you you want
to do it that way it's just it's just
better right and um
and so I started feeling guilty about
that so again for me that's like why do
I feel bad about this why is my
conscience speaking to me yeah yeah it
was it was weird and then I remember I
read Because mind you I'm going to
church still I started reading uh the
Bible one night because I would read the
Bible people be like yeah just read the
Bible and so I'd be like flustered get
one and get high and I'd open the Bible
and read like two lines and be like this
doesn't help and I'd Chuck it across
like I was you know I would try and so
I'm calling on God but nothing was
happening like I'm like what is
nothing's working and so and I always
tell that to people because a lot of
times we think God is like
hey I'm ready for you come on come do
this for me now well that's what the new
age people say I'm going to manifest
yeah in this reality so I'm I'm in
charge I'm whatever I want I'm gonna get
it if I just if I just think hard enough
yeah it's like that's not you're not God
that's how that works that's why I
always tell them three out of three
right now yeah that's real manifesting
make a tree grow you know
and uh you know so it's like this so one
night I read the um the Bible I get home
to church I open the Bible and I serve
in first Samuel and I don't know what
happened but I got pulled into this
story like it was the best thing that I
had ever read and I'm reading this stuff
like what like you know which part it
was it was the whole thing about the Ark
of the Covenant and Eli's Sons you know
tampering with the sacrifices and God's
like I'm taking the Covenant and you
know what I'm saying or the Dark of the
cup and it was like yo this is crazy you
know it's a crazy story this is and and
what was wild is it was true when I read
it I said this is real and I said this
is so cool
and then that was about it I kept going
with my life will I get a new car this
is three weeks after I wrecked the other
car I get a new car my dad takes me to
get a car pick this car up
and I'm sitting there my dad even says
he says I have a bad feeling about this
because I you know I have my I don't
even really technically have my
restricted license at that time was I
had the DUI I'm out of bond for a DUI
and uh and I get the car I have it for
20 minutes I'm on my way home I took
tags off my dad's van put it on I'm like
I'm going straight home get tags and all
that so I'm driving it super legally
don't have insurance nothing buy this
car and I'm I'm 20 minutes down the road
and and I'm going to switch lanes I'm
out of light to turn left there's a
light to go straight and I look over my
shoulder twice I'm sober and everything
there's no there's no cars coming and I
go to pool out and all of a sudden this
car comes over the hill going like 60
miles an hour and just just crushes my
car like I mean folds it in half carries
me into the middle of the intersection
and then somehow the car turned back
straight and I said oh no I said I'm out
of here and I started trying to drive
away but then I said oh my my insurance
my name's in the reg or the title is
crushing the glove box so I said I think
I should pull over so so I pull over I
get arrested for that driving on
suspended they charge everything's my
fault because just because I wasn't
licensed right right it was all on me
um so that happened I get out my you
know my Mom feels bad she's she comes to
the scene she like I'm I'm upset I'm
like dude I'm trying my best to get
ahead in life you know I'm trying not to
do hair when I'm doing my like
everything's just so my life is like
just crumbling around me and it was like
everywhere I turned disaster Mayhem and
so I'm like and I get home and then a
week later I get kicked out of my my
basement for having like someone over or
whatever and the landlord kicks me up
and then they have something hidden in
the lease where it was like they don't
have to give me a notice and I guess I
signed that probably you know I know him
yeah so I was like yeah you got three
days and you're out so now I'm homeless
um so this is this is like
uh June 2016 or 2017.
and uh so I've been out for a year now
I'm homeless everything just kind of hit
the fan at this point you know perfectly
worked out where
everybody had kind of turned their back
on me as far as like friends that were
kind of there all those relationships
started falling apart my parents they
still love me they're so there for me
but it was like they were not buying any
more cars the cars are out they're done
yeah like you're on your own and you
know I respect that you know that was it
was due time so all that is is kind of
there
and uh and now I'm just there in the in
the woods you know and I'm going into
this really like dark place of just
being comfortably numb again I'm just
like I'm working on Fridays and and uh
you know and so here where everything
shifted was about a month into this I
was working on Fridays one night and
this lady came up to me and she said God
said you need to see them and I stopped
going to church like three months prior
this was a lady from church that came up
to you no lady that I worked with she
came up to me she said God said that you
need to see him and I was like yeah I
know I said how do I get in touch with
them how do I make a meeting yeah let's
do this you know I'm ready so
but it's hit me something I was like
because at this point I believe there's
a God I know there's spirit I know the
spiritual world is 100 real there's not
a shadow in my mind that that is is real
so I really am aware I'm like that was
really weird but but you know but but
it's an Italian expression
between uh doing between saying and
doing is a whole wide ocean you know you
can say it because I know intellectually
this is true but okay what are you gonna
do right right yeah and that's kind of
where I was at was like all right I'll
talk to him go to him but that was you
know I this has been a year where I'm
crying out to him nothing's really
happened yet yeah yeah
um
and so I go to the the AAA meeting I go
to AAA meeting down the street and I
leave the and go into the chapel and I'm
going into the chapel and uh I said all
right God I'm here what do you want
I sit down
nothing happens I read the Bible I just
open it and I read this this page don't
think anything of it leave a week later
I come back I do the exact same thing I
don't know why though I'm going to the a
meeting because I'm trying to get my
life together but I something pulls me
into the chapel hey God I'm here again
what do you want open the Bible and I
get halfway through reading through it
and I realize oh this is the same exact
verse I read the last time I was here
Psalm 18. and so I'm like what that's
crazy so now all of a sudden something's
got my attention
and so now about let's fast forward
maybe like a week now everything starts
rapidly moving right so a week later I
was with some guys in the woods they
smoked this stuff called K2 it started
off as like an incense and you know they
would sell it at the gas stations well
it it leveled up and now it's it's like
a whole other thing it's very very like
powerful it's like the the drug is
incense it started off it was like an
incense and you'd smoke and it would it
would resemble weed yeah you know but I
never liked it because it just didn't
feel right you know it was like somebody
wasn't right and um
and so basically
I would see these guys bug out on it
like they would be slumped over be
acting crazy and I was like there is no
way that this does that and so I'm gonna
test that for myself yeah yeah and
that's really what it was because I'm in
my mind so I do real drugs you know like
this is there's no way this does that
and so they told me they said just take
one hit it's like they're so strong and
I said no I hit it like three times
and next thing I know as soon as I like
pass it to someone
I at this point I've overdosed on heroin
like four or five times so I I I know
what it feels like to like you know
there's a split second of just your body
registering whatever you just did was
too much for us and so next thing I know
is I just hear them saying oh he's going
out and I just feel myself falling to
the ground and I start to crawl and then
next thing I know I'm in a in a a dream
world right and in this dream world I'm
walking down a path there's demons on my
left and demons on my right
and they're they're basically laughing
at me they're like they're different
sizes they have these little robes they
have these big Grins and I'm but I'm
like not really paying attention to them
because I'm following another one it had
its back to me
and so we're walking on this Hall and we
get to this big door and so right before
we get to the door it says one more step
you're almost there
and it turned around and when it looked
at me it was an ugly demon and I said
hell no and I turned around and when I
turned around I woke up in a pool of
sweat and so I was that one that was
like another hook where just like what
the heck was that that was not normal
what do they look like they look like
little like Gremlins like almost like
the uh the you know from Lord of the
Rings the little guy that chases the
ring I think I don't even think I ever
watched that movie for real but I know
the little guy little you meant the real
thing so yeah they look kind of like
that the ones I've seen it they're just
ugly they're they're like they're
deformed like almost like little like
almost like you see in horror movies
like that's what they look like and and
there some of them be like three feet
tall someone would be like six feet tall
you know like they were different sizes
and they're just there's ugly but they
all had these big smiles it's like these
like like these is mocking they're like
these mocking Spirits or something and
and so that happened
and uh a week after that I go to see my
my grandma and I'm with my dad and so I
go to see her and I go out one night
and I come home and uh I had I went to
the bar I was drinking and stuff and I'd
come back and I'm sleeping with my uncle
you know like he it was like two couches
and a long bed or whatever connected so
I'm sleeping in the bed with him
basically and I'm about to fall asleep
and
I start hearing the TV
start I'm watching American Pickers I'm
halfway asleep so I'm awake and I'll
never forget their voice is changing
their demonic voices so their voices
turn into demon voices and they start
saying talking about me and I said I
don't know if uh like have you ever
heard like sleep paralysis yeah I had it
once certainly maybe twice yeah and it's
it's very scary right is it sound
because it sounds like you're demons
yeah whatever you do and you lose
control of your body like yeah you can't
move so you're just there hearing I
forget what I just heard like a weird
demon voice and I was I was awake but I
couldn't move my body I thought
the hell you know what is this and then
you know 30 seconds later it was over I
could move again
yeah I had to look I said what was that
you know and it's sleep paralysis and
you know it's funny actually to
backtrack real quick when that first
started because I had it a lot it first
started happening when I started doing
Buddhism
the first time I started having sleep
paralysis was when I started getting
deep into Buddhism I started having it
all the time and it freaked me out but
it also intrigued me so it was right
this this double-edged thing where it
scared me but then when it wouldn't
happen I'd kind of be like no I want to
see what happens if I stay in there and
like don't fight it um
but anyways that starts happening so I'm
in sleep paralysis it feels like
something's getting in my body like I'm
like this it's like something's trying
to get in my body and the TV says his
name's Josh he's from Virginia we need
to destroy them
they're talking about me I'm hearing it
and I'm feeling something in my body
next thing I know I'm like
finding myself on the floor
and I guess I was like screaming crying
or something my dad said like I woke up
the whole house making these moans or
whatever
they come downstairs I'm like I'm good
I'm good and I lay back down well when I
lay back down all of a sudden I'm having
something tell me to kill my uncle in my
head I'm something's telling me kill
your uncle
and I you know there's obviously there
was no reason to think that or want to
do that so I'm sitting here thinking
like what why where is this thought
coming from and while I'm saying no I'm
also simultaneously getting up to do it
so it's like I'm on autopilot getting up
and I find myself standing over my uncle
and something like just crush his head
like just just squeeze his head like and
and I started going like this over his
head and then his eyes popped up open
and he's like and he freaked him out
obviously and he went in the other room
you know and he went and went and slept
somewhere else
so that was number two that was like uh
wake up number two as far as like the
demons demonic realm right
so now my dude demons are really real
like there's no doubt about it and I'm
getting kind of freaked out yeah and um
and so I come home and there's another
couple weeks passed and uh and so
basically like I come to this place
where I want to go to a rehab
um and so I'm in a hotel room one night
and I said I'm gonna get high one more
time at this point I think I was clean
off heroin for like three months but I
was shooting up like crack and all those
types of and I didn't even I didn't even
like it I was just doing any like
whatever was around as long as it wasn't
heroin huh I would do it and so and you
think you're going to rehab so all right
one more for the road
yeah yeah and that's that's so stupid
but everybody thinks that way but it
doesn't matter what it is you're like oh
well you know one more for the road yeah
tomorrow that's not clean up yeah and
same thing with getting out of jail you
know that the overdose uh statistics are
it's you're 129 times more likely to
overdose within two weeks of getting out
of jail or like a program that's like
crazy you know times but um that's what
it was it was three months I was like
I'm gonna get high one more time and uh
I remember I was sitting in the bathroom
and I mean at this point I was pretty
broken you know like I was pretty what
am I gonna do and um and I started
talking to God I said you know Lord I
said
I I said this in a prayer I said I did I
went to church
I I literally called on you to help me
every time I went to go buy drugs I
begged you to help me and stop me I said
what else do you want from me I said
this is all I know I'm sitting here
looking at these drugs I hate these
drugs this is all I know what else do
you expect from me I said forgive me and
I started saying the Lord's Prayer while
I was tying my arm and doing all the
stuff I started saying Our Father who
are in heaven while I was doing it I
said forgiveness is it that's all I know
and so I subconsciously knew I was an
overdose because I knew I was doing too
much it wasn't intentional but I was
just like you know what I hope it kind
of happens but I don't I'm not trying to
make it happen but if it does whatever
and um and so that's a really
I think I get what you're talking about
but I couldn't articulate that that
you're saying it's not intentional but I
knew it was too much and I was doing it
anyway but it wasn't quite intentional
but like it wasn't not intentional
either yeah it was it was just
the hopelessness it's just like whatever
happens will be that kind of thing like
just you know I'm and um even though you
know what's gonna happen he's like well
whatever it's out of my hands even
though I know exactly what's going to
happen I did but I also there it's funny
because you get this like this Pride
when you get an addiction there's this
Pride associated with it where you build
up tolerances yeah like I had overdose
like I said like four or five times and
and and so you build up this this ego
with it where you're like I'll be good I
I came back the last time I'm good so
you get this Pride with it and so that's
that's what it was like yeah I think I'm
gonna I'll be right though yeah that's
what I thought so
um I did it
and I instantly again my body goes into
fight mode like I said I stand up I said
run like just keep your body moving
because I knew I had I felt that feeling
of like that comes before an overdose
it's very the Split Second of knowing
and I ran out the door and actually I
know I'm in an ambulance and so I'm
waking up in aiming it's like oh no
again and because now I'm thinking my
first thought is I had drugs I had a
needle you know cops and so
um I wake up they're you know they
revive me and the cop says you know now
you're going to jail if you you said you
do you want to go to the hospital I said
no he said all right all right then you
go in the other place yeah
and uh that was the moment that really
everything changed I go to jail I'm in a
suicide watch
so they take basically the jail
experience and make it worse you know
it's like they take all your clothes you
don't get the regular food and I'm
sitting in there and I I basically was
like you know what um Going Through Hell
on Earth I mean and I remember I looked
over on my cell wall and it said cold
hell on the on the wall
I'm on my phone my mom's you know crying
she's like you almost died again
everything's hitting me it was like for
the first time my life all my choices
smacked me in the face in a different
way like I always knew I was just
screwing up but this time it was like
God put everything just in a pile right
in front of me and I'm in this room
going through literally withdrawals from
multiple things and just having to sit
there and look at it and knowing there's
nothing like you can't go anywhere for
five days and all I said was God have
mercy God have mercy uh our father I
said the Lord's Prayer over and over
that's all I could do
and I said if you help me I said I'll be
a good boy that's all I want I said I
just want to be a good boy I said Lord I
don't I won't go to the bar anymore I
only want a girlfriend I said I just
want to be good that was how it just I
was done and um I get out I go to the
they transmitted the little pod
and I sit there for like three days and
I remember because in in a jail pod
people do nothing it's like people just
sit there and talk about Terrible Things
play cars or watch TV that's that's all
that they're doing it's like the most
miserable way to spend your time you
know and I said George Bernard show us
said that hell is the place where you
have nothing to do all day but amuse
yourself let's see I guess we'll play
cards now I guess we'll let's talk about
crime now do whatever yeah that's what
it was and I sat there and I said
I'm not doing this again I just because
I just did the 18 months like 11 months
prior yeah I said oh no I said I'm not
and I know in my mind I brought back
another felony I'm already on probation
I have eight years over my head I said
I'm not doing this again in my mind I'm
like oh my gosh I'm probably here like
five years yeah I said I'm done they're
gonna toast me I'm done my life is over
I said well I'm not sitting in this pod
I'm gonna join a program something yeah
so there was this program called The
Mind dorm which was it stands for men in
a New Direction and it's in the Prince
William County Jail that I don't know
where else it is but um
so I I hear about this it's a
faith-based program in the jail and so I
go to it and I remember like everyone's
like dude don't go there they got rules
you can't cuss there you have to wake up
early like all this stuff right and I'm
like I don't care I'm not sitting here
with you guys
yeah are you not there okay cool then
I'm going so I walk in and uh the funny
thing is there was a friend of mine that
was there and I was supposed to move in
with them like two weeks later and he
disappeared he went to he got locked up
and so I walked and I'm assigned to his
bunker I'm like I guess we moved in
together one way or another you know and
uh and so I was there and after a week I
almost left because it was like you had
to wake up at six in jail you don't want
to be awake all day yeah I mean like you
want to sleep as late as you can and so
all this is happening
uh and I'm about to leave
but then one day it was probably the
second week I'm thinking about leaving
something spoke to me in my heart again
it was like this thought of why don't
you just try
it was just a thought that wasn't my
thought but it was so loud like kind of
like it it silenced everything I said
why don't you just try for once like
and I kind of thought about it I was
like you know what where else am I gonna
go I said when these speakers come in I
might as well listen if I gotta read the
Bible at this time of the day I might as
well read it what else are you going to
do exactly and so I started doing that
and
it was like a week went by next thing I
knew I wanted to read the Bible for fun
so when it was free time and everyone
was watching TV I'd be reading the Bible
uh and then I would start praying
mind you I'm going through withdrawal
still because suboxone withdrawals take
like a month I'm not sleeping I think
I'm doing if I'm lucky three years in
prison
and I'm somehow I'm starting to be
happier than I ever had been in my life
so it's just like this contradiction
going on but I'm feeling more alive
every day all of a sudden people would
come up to me and they'd be like dude
what happened to you you're different
uh one guy came up to me and he said he
said dude every time I'm having a bad
day he said when I look at you he said I
feel hope like because I just started
having this Joy it was it was and I
didn't know what was happening I'd look
at myself and be like what's happening
to you because
I just felt like I was changing and I
didn't I didn't connect the dots still I
still didn't connect that because there
was no moment there was like oh you know
burning bush it was just I would read
the word I'd pray and all of a sudden I
would like be in conversations and
they'd be talking about drugs and I'd be
like this is a stupid conversation I'll
go read my Bible and uh and that was
like the first thing I started noticing
about two weeks after that
I would start praying I'd be like in
prayer worshiping Jesus whatever
and it would just feel like a a love
bomb would fall on me of like it
reminded me of how I felt when I was on
mushrooms except it was a hundred times
more pure like that like uncontrollable
laughter and just Joy I fell on
mushrooms it made that look like Creek
Water compared to Dasani or something
you know what I mean it was like
thought that was Joy you know and and I
would have do mushrooms to have that Joy
but that wasn't even real joy that was
like artificial artificial Joy I was
laughing I thought it was Joy but I was
I was I was getting like covered in this
just love and I mean it was it freaked
me out because I I literally felt like I
was high almost like it was like I was
high on life and like I was just I'd be
laughing I had Joy all I want to do is
read my Bible and pray
and it just I mean it just took off
really like it just it I was there for
two months in this Cocoon of Jesus
and all that's all I wanted to do it was
like everything in my life made sense
like uh like I started knowing like oh
you have a purpose just everything came
together and um so basically what
happened was my lawyer was like you're
you're looking at like a year all right
I mean he said you're gonna stay in here
your low end is 18 months you're
probably looking at like two two years
or so like I was 18 months to three
years or something was the guidelines
yeah
so he said get comfortable
and I would I didn't care I had you
comfortable I was I really was and I
remember my mom came and she said you
know I'm gonna get a bomb and I said
praise God I said you know I said yeah
you know like I said Mom I met Jesus
he's real you know and and so I was like
dead serious in this like I was full and
fully in love I met him you know like it
was like every time I was calling his
name I was just it was and I'm not gonna
lie like and I I used it like a drug
like while I was there that first like
month I really would like I'd be like I
need to pray to Jesus so I could feel
this this Joy right and and that's how
it was and
um and so I was just getting this
changed like radically and I remember
one night I prayed and I said Lord I
said if you get me out of here I said
I'll pray for every person I see I said
I'll do whatever you want me to do I
said I'm I'm 100 in and and I said you
don't owe me anything like I I made this
bed I get it you know but that'd be cool
right I said to be cool Lord if you get
me a Christian halfway house so I can
bond out so I can look good for court at
least you know I'll still do the time
but I look better in their eyes so like
a week later my lawyer comes in he's
like hey I got a ticket out of here for
you I got this Christian halfway house
he said uh he said you get a bed to bed
transfer it's a six-month program if you
complete it you know the judge would
probably work with you
and so I did that and in that time it
was like my relationship with God just
took a whole new like a whole it just
kept growing and I remember knowing like
if I don't stick to this with everything
I have I I'm gonna go back to what I was
doing and so I was in another state I
didn't tell anyone's home
and so yeah I mean and then a year later
I go to court
and the judge basically was like look
there's no point of locking up again my
PO loved me so she's writing good
reviews it's like I'm in a halfway house
you know like I have my job everything
is
and so that's the so so you then you
come to the end of that
and is that it is that happy happily
ever after you don't do drugs you don't
you know commit crimes or I guess you I
guess your your crimes were all drug
related so it's not like you were going
burglarizing yeah classes or anything uh
but is that it that's the end of the
story no no no no no the the
you know that's that's uh so okay so I'm
in this like evangelism mode right so I
I go because I have that addictive like
uh personality I'm all in for this Jesus
stuff well I'll tell you to I I don't
have a particularly addictive
personality when I I was an atheist for
10 years I reverted in my early 20s and
after a kind of slow process of first
believing that God exists and then you
know that the Bible is real Christ is
who he says he is and when it clicked
though
I had that same feeling of
what do I do now do I just have to I
just need to tell everybody I need to
whatever I am doing I need doesn't
matter I need to just go like do
and and I think this happens to all
converts and reverts or many of them a
friend of mine converted had this very
numinous experience where he he said I
was filled with the Holy Spirit I said I
could describe it for me it's like I
can't describe it for you buddy but I'll
tell you this it it when it happened to
me I was just totally bowled over and my
first prayer was Lord please don't make
me a Jesus Freak he said please don't
but you just feel and it's
funny in that
you're you've got the Zeal of a convert
so all you want to do is go out and talk
about it but you are probably rather
immature in your faith at this point
because it's so new and so in in a way
you're the best person to go evangelize
but in a way you're like the worst
person to go Advantage you just don't
you just haven't been doing it you know
it's not in your muscle memory exactly
yet and so and if you have an addictive
personality I'm sure it's that times ten
yeah no that's that's basically what it
was I was addicted to reading my Bible I
was addicted to praying and worshiping
and I was addicted to telling people
about Jesus that's exactly what it was
um and so that went on though for a
while that was my life uh to the point
where I mean honestly like I there was a
point where that first year
I didn't I worked as little as possible
at a Labor uh finders you know what I
mean as an attempt agency maybe like 50
a day just enough to pay rent for my my
halfway house and I would spend all my
free time going and praying for people
and evangelizing but yeah I treated it
like a job and so I spent my whole day
praying and then I go pray for people
come home pray go out and I did that for
a while and then so basically what
happened was
I got married uh a little over a year
after getting saved the girl that was
taking me to church ended up being my
wifey so it's convenient yeah so that
like invited another level of like just
life responsibility
um and so then I had to kind of change
how I was moving
and then I'd say a year after that
it was like I started reassessing
everything
um and basically what I mean by that is
I started to not feel that like Jesus
High every time I prayed I started to
not get those you know I always joke
around so the best intercessors of a
newborn again believer because it's like
when I first got saved every prayer was
getting answered like boom boom boom and
uh it was nice and then it got to the
point where it was like I had to wait
and knows or whatever yeah I explained
that to myself because there was when I
reverted in in those early years
you know it's weird it's really weird
how palpable it all is how how
just real it is all the time and
now looking back on it these things
still happen a lot you know everything
is rich in meaning and the world is
teeming in Miracles but I I look back on
it and I think oh I guess I just really
needed that I sometimes think it's God
saying hey you stupid idiot
why don't you get it and then after a
certain amount of time you don't need
that as much anymore yeah you know yeah
yeah that's the process of maturing
right it's like yeah yeah and I think
that's what it was was like I was used
to God being so on me kind of uh and
then it started to feel a lot more
distant and started to feel a lot more
like faith and uh and so I started to
basically just really get real
analytical I started to I got out of
that child like Faith or just believing
and just being and I started to
watch a lot of like atheists talk about
stuff I started to just I was just
questioning like because it was like
basically I got to this point where I
was like all right I know Jesus is real
I said how can I I don't like I feel
like I'm starting to get arrogant like
you know because I'm telling people I'm
out here preaching Jesus I'm telling
people they need to repent of sins I'm
I'm being that guy and I believe it I
you know I believe it for me but I'm
saying how do I know it's only for me
what if there was other ways for other
people like you know how like am I yeah
the idea of the technical term is
indifferentism what if what if all
religions are pretty much the same man
you know and yeah worship this part of
the elephant and I worship this whatever
you know that's right it was a very
popular idea it's yeah extremely wrong
but it's but it is a very popular idea
so you're exploring this and you're
saying well you know maybe
maybe what I'm doing is just one one
thing among many that we could do yeah
that's well and it was more of like
Jesus is the truth the way the life but
what if there's more to what's been
presented hmm you know like what if
there's more to this than just what I've
been finding in church uh you know I was
do you mean more in that other religions
are true or do you mean more in that
Christianity is about more than this
Christian is yeah so it was kind of like
maybe there's more to this than what we
we think and I started getting looking
into more like early church and and
started just just look just research
everything I mean I put my faith up on
the altar kind of and just was like just
trying to it was almost like I was
trying to crush my faith you know in in
an honest way of like look uh this is
where I'm at
and uh and then I started to get I guess
bitter that's what really started to
happen was I started to get bitter
because I was praying for people when I
was doing
you know God's work I thought
and I started to get prideful and feel
like well look out I'm doing this this
this and it wasn't like what you're not
doing something for me it was why aren't
you helping them like that's kind of how
I started to feel because I you know I I
come from addiction so I was trying to
help other addicts I'm trying to help
and it was like you know I was trying to
lead them to Jesus and it wasn't working
the way I thought it should and so I
started getting prideful I started
thinking I was God's you know boss
almost and and that's kind of because
you know I'm like well I've been doing
this for two years
um
I don't know what's really coming of it
my life has changed but I said I want to
see other people's lives change too or I
don't feel you know it's like I don't
feel like I could really
be confident in this if it's not
producing fruit for other people
and so I started I found this this in my
research one day I found this this
article about uh this Mystic group that
would basically took mushrooms as a form
of
um basically connecting to God like it
was normal and that's what the Bible
referred to as Manna so it was this
rabbit who I was they said that they
said that Manna was was mushrooms with
shrews wow they said it popped up every
morning like yeah when I read that
passage about the man it doesn't exactly
resemble shrooms to me but that's very
funny that they're saying this because
with mushrooms in particular but all of
it DMT acid all the Psychedelic stuff
there is this weird culture where if you
see a heroin addict on the street you
say oh there's a junkie there's another
bum hope he doesn't kill himself but
then someone says oh I do shrooms all
the time say wow you must be so
spiritual wow it is just like you're
both poisoning yourselves that's the
that is the uh the the aesthetic of it
though right yeah have that yeah
um no for me it was like I still had
these memories of the positive from it
so I stood at that point I hadn't
connected the dots to this was part of
the problem
in my mind I was the problem because I
was on drugs so now I'm starting to
think that seed is planted right that
was a prefiguring of your Enlighten of
your true Enlightenment which is
actually in this relationship with your
savior yeah yeah and it it basically
just started I didn't do anything with
it for a while it started to kind of
just Brew under the surface and I said
you know what Josh I said maybe because
you were on heroin and all this other
stuff what if now that you're clean you
haven't done hard drugs in a few years
um maybe now you can take mushrooms it's
natural I'm not talking about acid I'm
talking about mushrooms because they're
natural and now you could probably
connect with Jesus in a better way you
know that this relationship isn't as
Supernatural as it was in the beginning
yeah you're losing your yeah your your
tolerance is growing yeah yeah yeah
you're not feeling that high yeah and so
I said maybe mushrooms will do the trick
and and not only for that but also
maybe I can get some answers for other
people because I'm encountering this
question all the time about people doing
psychedelics and seeing it be a thing I
said you know God my heart is to like
like I I put my heart before God of like
look like this is where I'm at I said I
kind of feel like doing it and and you
know that's a worst case scenario I find
out it's not it's not good and you know
you know I I don't do it anymore yeah
well the thing about it is that you know
and I say I I say this as humble as
possible like I when I say I was in it I
mean like I really was sold out I was
living right I wasn't like a Christian
that was dabbling in sin and in the
world and going to church I mean I
literally was my life was dedicated to
this like that's all I thought about
that's all I did and you know like I
didn't have a life that was my life and
So like
um and so it wasn't like oh I was
already slipping away or something
and so um basically
uh months passed and so one night I'd go
to my friend's house and
we're gonna make music and while you
know he's loading up the beat and
everything
and this was a friend of mine that it
was like the one of like two friends
that I had that the old friends that I
didn't completely cut off yeah but it
wasn't you know it was more just like I
would make music with them I still loved
them so it's like I'd keep my distance
but show up and so anyways he he dumps
out his backpack of chocolate mushrooms
all over the right over the bed right in
front of me and he basically was like
here you know I mean here try one you
know I mean and now the thoughts of what
was I was thinking the last few months
pop up
and so I said you know what Josh I said
I'm tired of the internally I'm like you
know what I'm tired of the being fear
with this I just want to face this I
don't like the fear that like there's
there's this fear of I shouldn't do this
and I didn't like that you know like I I
said you know I don't like fear I'm
gonna confront this I'm gonna take it I
said it's now or never I'm not gonna sit
here and think about it anymore I was
tired of processing it in my mind I just
wanted to try it and I said you know
people get so sick of the anxiety and
the hemming and hawing and the moral
conscience telling you no no no that you
think well here's one way I can shut up
that moral conscience I'm just gonna do
it and then I won't have that anxiety of
anticipation anymore yeah yeah that was
I think that's probably what it was it
was like you know what if you don't do
it tonight it's just going to bother you
so yeah so I did it and I I ate the it
was a you know eighth of mushrooms and
just for context like that was the
normal dose that I would take that was
like a normal like go-to dose it's
definitely on the higher end as far as
like when you're looking at micro dosing
and stuff it's a lot lower than that but
I had taken much larger doses too I had
taken you know double of everything yeah
yeah and so so to me it was like this is
my kind of mild right that's how I'm
thinking
um so I take it and it starts off good
the first 20 minutes I'm just getting in
my My Vibe and you know and just
listening to the music and it's all good
vibes and good thoughts and I'm happy
and it's going to be good and then and
then at one point my friend says hey uh
my these guys want to go to the bar do
you want to come I said no I said I just
look what I was eight I don't want to go
to the bar and so he said well I'm gonna
go you can sit here if you want is that
cool I said all right guys I'm stuck
here now you know kind of thing and um
so he leaves
and and this stuff it takes like
probably 30 minutes to kick in so in the
meantime you start kind of feeling your
stomach will start to turn there's like
this this pre almost anxiety kind of
thing like you feel it kind of starting
to creep up on you
and so I already had feel that so I said
we're about to go into this
and so my friend he walks out the door
the second he walked out the door it was
like that feeling of sleep paralysis the
feeling of like demons and evil walks in
the room it was like this transfer like
he left and it was the first thing I
noticed was if I feel like I just got
set up unknowingly I feel like my friend
just set me up and he was used as a
vessel and had no idea completely not in
his mind knowing what he was doing but I
just got set up here like which you did
100 and that and that was so clear you
know I mean like I was like wow I just
got set up
and so he walks out
and evil just walks in mind you I have
had demonic encounters as a Christian at
this point just just based off doing
God's work and having demons come and
attack me and stuff I had cast out
demons and all that kind of stuff so I
know this presence yeah I'm still like
so 100 so reminded like I'm 100 in my
rational mind I feel it tangibly come in
the room I said oh I know that presence
and so I said oh no this isn't good and
so but I'm like all right I know how
mushrooms work
I'm gonna uh stay positive keep my mind
right this you know if I feed into this
so it's gonna get worse I start ignoring
it I said I'm good and and I go into the
bathroom
and I'm talking I'm cheering I'm giving
myself a pep talk in the mirror and I
said I said Josh I said you took
mushrooms I said it's all right you're
gonna be okay I said you can't die
and the second I said you can't die I
Heard a Voice speak in my heart the same
way I always have heard God speak to me
cross-check everything it says who says
I can't take your life whenever I want
who says like like and it wasn't in a
way of of like anger it was it was a
checking of my pride like who says I
just can't stop your heart whenever I
want like what do you mean you can't die
I could just do it now right like for no
reason you could just drop right so it
was like
oh I could but I you know like this
could be it and
and um so then I started being like oh
wow this isn't good I started feeling
like all right I need to start repenting
so I started praying I said and it was
like as soon as I started to pray and
started to ask God to help me
it just I felt like I just was getting
just like a dark cloud was just coming
around me I could tangibly feel it I
could feel like closing in on me
and I'm but I'm I'm still in this like
state of like
it's gonna be okay you're good and I'm
like you know what Jesus forgive me uh
you know how we think like oh I messed
up oh Lord forgive me and we're good
yeah yeah so it's like forgiveness
doesn't equate to consequence so it's
like right the consequences were still
there and then I realized oh no I opened
this door right I know better I'm not a
baby
uh I'm I'm you know a young child and
God I knew better and so now it's all
hitting me like oh
what'd you do like this is and you just
opened this door this is and you're
gonna be stuck in this place because now
I know I already have my spiritual eyes
open sober minded in the natural so now
that I'm spiritually awake and not dead
in sin
now when I actually open that Veil
it's not gonna be nothing it's gonna be
clear I'm gonna know what it is now
and so I started praying and I'm just
feeling like death encompassed me that's
what it talks about Psalm 18 death
Encompass me you know um and that's what
it feels like and I'm
I called my wife and I said she was on
out with friends at dinner I said you
need to come get me she had no idea what
I was doing I didn't even I wasn't
planning this right I can't imagine she
would have approved yeah yeah and she
said she doesn't know and it's starting
to get worse as before like leading up
to when she got there it started to feel
like something was pulling like sort of
feel like my spirit was
wanting to go somewhere I can't explain
it's like it felt like the light was
flickering within like it was like
someone's pulling me somewhere and so it
was like
she by the time she gets there I'm in
the I'm not able to really function at
this point I couldn't breathe well
and so she's trying to talk like she
thinks this is just normal Josh coming
in the car like hey why would anyone and
I said I can't talk and I said just pray
I said just pray from I didn't even have
time to explain to her what was going on
by this point I was I couldn't breathe
it was I was and she's even like she's
like what what's wrong like because I'm
like
I'm gasping for breath
and I'm feeling my body like go get go
in and out it's like I'm here talking to
you and then next thing you know it's
like boom snapped into like a dream room
it's like like in and out like in and
out of Consciousness and then because it
would be a black void so we're going
through this whole car ride and every
now and then I'll try to like tell her
like just I can't talk right now you
know I'm like over like 30 minutes I
gave her the story like oh I took
mushrooms all right you know and so I
get home by the time I get home it was
just full like it was just fully on
I run into my room I lay on the floor
and at this point I'm just getting
pulled like I I just I'm feeling my
soldiers get pulled out of my body and
so I'm in this dark like void
and uh
next thing I know I start there starts
to be like sight coming to it because
it's just a abyss of Blackness and so
I'm sitting there and all of a sudden I
realize I'm in this giant hand
so I'm in this hand and then I see
demons right in front of me
and it's all the same demons I've seen
in that one overdose it's like like I
don't know if they were the exact same
ones but they look the same it was the
same breed same breed yeah and except
this time
there was like taller ones like it was
like they were the ones in charge like
they were they were higher ranking ones
so I'm in this hand
and now I'm in another another reality
and now fears like what is going on
where am I what is the the first thing
that hits you is you're helpless that's
I think the first thing that really got
me even before this happened like up to
this point it's knowing like what who
are you gonna call like what are you
gonna do what do you know it's not like
when you're a kid you call your mom to
help you and you know like there's
nothing you can do the hospital can't
help you this is you know what I mean
like this is
there's nothing you can do right now so
you're just helpless yeah so I'm in this
uh you know I'm in this hand
and and I'm seeing these demons
and so the one stands up
and it's and and then I'm looking like
my attention that once that one stands
up
I like my attention diverts and now it
was like this this light Tower like I it
was like this thing if it was just
tilted up and just lights just with no
walls but you could see it just a big
light beam Tower kind of thing with
different colors and I knew that was
like the kingdom of heaven and then I
knew that I was in outer darkness of
some sort I was in this this in between
place
um and so now this demon stepping
forward and he's presenting a case to
this this Tower
and he said we're tired of this kid he
keeps coming into our kingdom taking
people out and then he came back and ate
off our table
and it hit me right then and there
you're an evangelist you're winning
souls for Jesus all the time you you
really are coming into you know and I
what I'd go into to you know
wherever inner cities wherever any
neighborhood just preach Jesus talk
about Jesus get people say you know what
I mean but you could bring a thousand
people into the church and you could
wind up in the bad place uh-huh 100 what
a phrase
he keeps taking Souls at it or you know
helping Souls out of here but then he
comes and eats from our table
even Peter craved the
Theologian philosopher he says that
abortion is the Demonic inversion of the
Eucharist the Eucharist the priest holds
up the consecrated host and says recites
the word of Our Lord says this is my
body which will be given up for you and
what abortion does is uses the same
words to a diabolically opposite end
which is this is my body this is my body
and I'm gonna I won't save I'll kill for
my body right
and and even this this idea of
the Eucharist is manna from Heaven it's
a that's that's what what you're seeing
the figure of of the Eucharist in the
manna that comes down and saves the
Israelites gives them bread to eat and
we we now have this in the Holy
Communion
and
as you said earlier this this idea that
no man you know what if the mushrooms
are the ACT that's kind of like the
Manna but
the demons are telling you in this trip
they're saying
that's our food from our table that he's
eating 100 and that and that was
I mean like that was the the uh the Crux
of the whole thing for me because at
that point the thing about the spirit
realm is you don't need a lot of words
to get a lot of Revelation and nothing
is spoken this is all telepathically
it's it's just known and the spirit
nothing is hidden all things when the uh
nothing is hidden from the light right
like so in the spirit everything is just
it's it's out on open you don't have
money to hide behind you don't have a
facade you don't have your your
everything that you try to ignore is
there whether you like it or not and
it's seen and so it was that moment of
being naked before everything
of me being a hypocrite in that moment
be me backsliding me whatever I was
everything was there oops
you know oops and and now it was a
matter of I'm in this hand that I I
can't just get out of this all right see
you like later guys you know it was it
was this is serious this was I was in in
the courts of Heaven I mean that's it
was literally they were presenting a
case against me to God and and
and so I'm sitting there now I'm
freaking out in the sense that I already
was feeling my body what was going on it
felt like everything was shriveling up
you know um it's like you could feel
your organs drying up fear becomes a
jacket you like a living thing that
comes around you
um just despair just I mean every every
negative like emotion feeling you could
think of is there and then it's
heightened and it's I felt like a slug
if you pour salt on it I felt my life
literally just getting pulled out of me
shriveling up and while I'm in this hand
I feel my breath just getting pulled out
of me and mind you in in in real time I
you're you feel like you're connected to
your physical body so I'm still like
five ten percent aware of what's
happening in my body
and every you know 10 15. my wife's
freaking out you know and during this
time she's freaking out yeah she doesn't
know what to do she thinks should I call
hospitals what should I do but I know
what's going on so I'm telling her just
pray for me just keep praying just like
like that I was like just pray and then
I'd get pulled back into and I'd be in
this reality and so because you're
you're not in
physical danger of death any more than
any of us is at any given moment if you
were on heroin or something you would
have been in physical danger of death
but as you said consciously you said
these are mushrooms mushrooms at this
dose they're not gonna kill you God
tells you well
I can stop your heart whenever I want
right so but that's that's different
it's not the mushroom so you know if
your wife had said hey you're high on
heroin or something
and and you said well don't call the
doctors you probably would have just
called the doctors anyway because
there's a poison that's going but but
what you're saying is no my danger right
now
though it I feel it physically the
danger that I'm in right now is a
spiritual danger for sure and I mean to
be honest with you to this day I don't
know how like if it was just spiritually
I would have died or like it felt
physical that's the thing physically my
body was was not functioning like
physically it felt physical and the
reason I say that is because people get
this idea that like like I said like oh
you can't die from this you can die from
that there's you know this this
spiritual realm is what is really
deciding the Physical Realm so it's like
that was a major infraction yeah the the
technical uh language for this is that
the matter is
just like the stuff that's in the the
spiritual realm is the form it's this
like our soul is the substantial form of
our body right and so people try to
really neatly separate these two things
but that's not really how it works you
are your soul you are your body those
things are together
inseparably for now in this in this
world and so to try to say well no
that's just happening to my spirit it
has no effect on my body or this just
happening to my body it's what are you
talking about you're both
that's and that's so that's like one of
the greatest Mysteries I'm going to get
into right now but that's I mean that's
the mystery of it all or not even really
the mystery that's the truth behind it
is that that's like like the spirit
world is happening right now well we're
sitting here talking so that's what the
first thing it showed me was
my body's literally laying there my soul
is literally in in the spirit Realm so
this is happening right now so when you
see people physically going through
something you don't know what is
happening spiritually a lot of times
right so so anyways this is happening so
I'm feeling this
this whole thing going on in my in my
body I'm literally losing breath I'm
crying out for God to have mercy but I'm
thinking at this point like God heard me
by now like like either he forgives me
or he doesn't so I'm kind of like I
started to give up because it was
exhausting me it was physically like it
was giving me like it was taking all my
strength to speak to say God have mercy
uh forgive me
I just felt the longer I was in his hand
the more I was life was getting pulled
out of me and uh and at one point I
started to give up I said you know what
Jesus forgive me I made a big mistake
I'm a sinner I believe in you for my
salvation I said I'm Letting Go like I'm
gonna give up I'm done fighting this
thing right now and so I started to
relax
and I started to but I'm still going
through turmoil I start but I started to
think about my wife was pregnant at the
time I have another kid I sort of think
about that
and I said no I can't I said God I said
uh you know what it's not about me I
said my kid needs me and so that hit me
that was the next thing that happened
was oh these people need me so I said
God just said save me for them you know
and um
and so at that moment I started to feel
almost a slight like pressure release
and then I started to notice that at the
top of the tower like it was like I
couldn't look at it I knew you know it's
the glory of God was up there I couldn't
I couldn't go look at it I knew it was
there
but I can see the rest of the Tower and
I could see the the source of that Tower
was at the top of it that was giving
life to the rest of it and all of a
sudden breath started coming like I
could I could see like a little like
breath would hit me and then I'd feel it
hit me
and then in that moment I said every
breath that I get is he's literally
giving it to me he's aware that he's
giving it to me consciously giving it to
me and it was like I was it was like I
would get the breath and it would and I
would make it last because it was like
there was space in between it wasn't
like I could just like how we could
breathe now just as freely as we want I
couldn't breathe freely I was breathing
according to the like and it's a
beautiful
metaphor
and of course as we're speaking here
there's really no such thing as a
metaphor or literal I mean what we're
saying is these
these two things intersect right
physical and the metaphysical and that
you say you couldn't breathe and then
God gives you that breath and this is
the image of that's that is what the
holy spirit is right I mean the bond of
love between the father and the son and
this procession of
it says he spoke the everything into
existence and then it says his breath
made man breathing and gave the being uh
the hosts I'm now witnessing this maybe
they've received the Holy Spirit crisis
right breathe something yeah yeah yeah
wow and that's so that I'm now I'm
sitting with that but it's like I start
to get hope because I didn't have hope
at that point like I was just kind of
just
I didn't know what to think it was just
I was just in pain and and confusion but
also like just just discomfort so now I
start to feel like maybe there's hope
now
and um
so now the the breath starts coming more
fluidly and I'm starting to like kind of
ease up
and then all of a sudden it was like
this uh this uh cloud of witnesses kind
of came around right and the Bible talks
about that so this these Saints start
coming out
and they I knew they were praying for me
I just started to feel energy love come
from them and as they began to pray for
me I started to feel more alive and then
all of a sudden it was like a shadow of
a cross came out the top of the tower it
was like a cross came out and it was
like the the source of the top his
attention turned to it
and it was this because like I said
everything's telepathically and like
it's all connected like you you know
what's what everything is kind of
feeling and thinking in a sense
uh so it's like I I could feel God's
attention turn to the cross and remember
and then all of a sudden I look over and
out of the the tower Jesus starts
walking out I see this man come walking
towards me out into the the center of
this Abyss
he puts his arm around me he looks at
everything all the demons he looks he
put his arm around me he said this one's
mine he belongs to me and as soon as he
touched me
I went back to my body and began going
through Deliverance
because Jesus you can't Jesus can't
touch you and so everything that I had
just allowed into my life I literally
was puking like I never had a painful
vomit like that I was puking my guts out
filling up garbage bags little like
shopping bags which is common I mean
this is people maybe not as intensely as
what you're describing but people always
talk about this really
spiritual experience of ayahuasca
they all vomit a bunch yeah you think
that doesn't seem so beautiful yeah and
even the beauty of that image though
where Christ walks out
and touches you and you're back in the
body which is
it's an incarnational Faith the pivot of
history is the Incarnation of the second
person of the Trinity Son of God into
flesh and he was incarnate of the Holy
Spirit born of the Virgin Mary and
becomes man the fact that God the son
becomes man is this height this
Perfection of the unity of
physical and metaphysical you think no
the body the body actually does matter
we actually are these things and you see
this in the sacraments that he gives us
so this is this bread is my body yeah
how do you make sense of it it only
makes sense in an incarnational Faith so
the second he touches you
oh yeah there's the body again all right
oh there I am
that's that's you gave me a piece of it
because the the fine thing about this
story is there's so so much that I'm
still peaceful probably the rest of my
life I'll be piecing together parts of
it
and so I'm I go through Deliverance I
Collapse I puke my guts out I think it's
over because I Collapse I feel kind of
that release of like it's gonna be okay
and I Collapse but now when I CL like
I've collapsed on the floor I I go back
but this time I'm in that Tower
and when I'm in the tower now I'm in the
light I know the darkness is behind me
I'm looking at Jesus face to face and
it's like hit you don't see everything
else it's like everything else Fades
away like a cinematic you know on your
iPhone all I could see was his eyes and
his eyes were like
um like almost like the Earth like they
were multiple colors it wasn't just like
oh they're blue or brown it was like
there were shades of green there was
shades of blue it was just like they
they they they they magnetically like
pull you into him and then it also
simultaneously pulls itself into you
it's like this like this so everything's
just fading away and it's just he's
staring eyes he smiles at me and the CR
so he's smiling at me as if he's happy
to see me I'm thinking about what just
happened
but he's looking at me as if like he was
happy to see me
and he said maybe we shouldn't do that
again and he smiled at me like
I love you and so in that moment
oh man it's like what do you what do you
do with that in in the moment I'm
receiving that but I'm still stuck in
what happened in the past you know but
I'm also now scripture is flooding my
mind I'm thinking about Psalm 73 for
whom do I have in heaven but besides you
who do I decide on earth like literally
Jesus is all we have in heaven that like
it's because of him it's him alone like
we have nothing else on our side there's
nothing else or like he's he's it
and so that's hitting me like oh you're
the one you're the one that came for me
no one else there was no one else that
could have came for me it was you yeah
the Saints are praying for you right but
he comes for you yeah but and it's it's
through him so it was like yeah like and
so that's all hitting me
and so he like starts like walking with
me
but I started to notice because I'm
looking around and and it wasn't like I
was seeing everything as clear as I'm
seeing this room
it was almost like there was a sheet
over it so everything was kind of veiled
but I could see it so I could make out
oh this is this kind of color oh there's
there's a being there so I'm seeing
light beings kind of
and I'm seeing that there's stuff around
there's life around
but I'm sensing that things like that
these like Angels or these these Saints
whatever they were were kind of
disappointed in me not mad at me but it
was kind of just like you knew better
Josh like kind of thing like you know
not it wasn't a shaming way it was just
like
that's just what it is it this is what
it was it was just kind of like this
wild I guess it shouldn't be wild that
you describe it that way because this is
the scene in Dante's Divine Comedy in
Paradise
something I'm always struck by when I I
love the poem and when Dante gets up to
heaven
he has wonderful conversations with
these people one of his ancestors Saints
and the object of his love well the
ultimate object of his love is God but
he is he is sort of channeling it
through this
beloved Beatrice and Beatrice sends
Virgil down on this mission to you know
go pull Dante out of his midlife crisis
and the Wayward way and pull him down
through the pits of hell up to Purgatory
up into heaven but she's not
nice to him and she the first thing she
says to him when she sees him at the end
of purgatory going into heaven is she
says he's crying because Virgil goes
away and he is virtual is a pagan can't
go to heaven and she says stop crying
cut it out we gotta go and then she goes
up and she's fairly Steely faced and
she's looking at God
and he can see in the reflection of her
eyes he that's how he's he's looking at
her eyes and he's seeing God reflected
there and but she's not she's not saying
oh hey buddy good to see you oh attaboy
she's they're saying no reality is what
reality is and I'm not gonna I'll pray
for you but I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
for you and that's what I think it like
we get sometimes this idea that like
angels in heaven and Jesus is like this
teddy bear like oh you know like and
it's like they're serious Jesus was
about his father's business this is like
a serious God's about his will being
done so it's like this isn't a game you
know it's like like why are we referred
to as armies and sports players and you
know like and soldiers church militant
right and so it that was very clear to
me and so with that
I couldn't accept it like shame just hit
me all of a sudden and I took off like
it's like I took off where I was at
there was levels to it was different uh
like dimensions of Glory where he
brought me was a Higher One I knew there
was one or two above me
and I knew there was at least three or
four under me so when I looked down I
said I'm going to the lowest part of
Heaven I could find as low as I can just
I want to stay here good strategy good
advice and good strategy yeah so I took
off I mean I like you think it and you
just travel you go you're there so next
in I'm at the ground and I'm on my knees
and I'm just worshiping I didn't want to
look at anything I said God Don't Make
Me Speak ever again I'm not worthy to
speak I I said uh all I want to do is
worship I said just let me worship and
so that was like the next thing that
that 100 hit me of you're giving me this
breath
the only thing that I should do with it
is give it back to you in a way that
pleases you so it's like I don't really
want to like just let me worship that's
the only that's the only heart response
to what's going on right now and to
where this this realizing where I'm at
I'm not I shouldn't be here but then
Jesus came down
and he comforted me you know it was like
this this just moment of Let It Go like
just you're here embrace it so I I
started to send back with him and then
it was like I switched I wasn't with him
anymore
I was in this this almost this bubble of
like
just like colors was like flying by me
and it was like downloads were just
flooding through me I felt like I was
hooked up to a machine you see people
like hooked up to those machines they're
like like that's what it felt like I
felt like I was hooked up to this
machine and every question I had was
just flooding through me to the point
where I said stop you're gonna kill me
it was it was like it was like God's
love and his wrath his grace and
everything was all mixed in one almost
it was like this you're being just too
good to me I don't deserve it it was
like all and everything I want to know
is is coming to me everything I could
ever think about in my life and wanting
to understand is coming to me I'm
getting all the it's just flooding me
I'm it's just hitting oh all
simultaneously in a matter of minutes
it's like download everything made sense
and I literally was crying out to stop I
said stop showing me this stop showing
me this it's gonna kill me it's gonna
kill me it's gonna kill me and then next
thing I know I just um I just started it
started like lightening up and then I'm
back in my body
[Music]
and it was just like
it's over like but it but I didn't
really want it to be you know like over
now because now I'm like it it was like
all right well you see the same
um experience that you're describing
when when God's face passes by in
Genesis let's say
don't look directly at you can't you
will die if you look directly at the
face of God like you you look at the
back of his head you can but the the
sense that you'll be overwhelmed because
you're finite yeah and
so you can't comprehend God it is not
that's not going to work yeah it's like
if he were totally comprehensible by you
he wouldn't be God and you wouldn't be
you right no I mean remind me of like
when Paul said there's things I've seen
I can't tell you yeah
it's like and I see through a veil half
directly yeah yeah you're describing
this Veil right it was too much for my
my natural body to contain and you know
what you you reminded me of something
when you're talking about Dante's
Inferno uh and I haven't talked about
this really yet but
what what was because I was baptized
Russian Orthodox which is I think very
similar to Catholic faith um and
somebody asked me they're like have you
heard of the toll houses
and um so when I started looking in the
toll houses I was like I really feel
like that's what I experienced you know
and I so I didn't get this so after but
it's I think it's similar to like
Purgatory
um and and and that's what so I've been
looking you won't cut out until you pay
the very last far thing that sort of
thing that's kind of how it felt I don't
I mean I don't know I just when I read
about what toll houses are I'm like
that's definitely what it seemed like I
was going through that definitely what
it felt like
um because there was a period of
of hell it was it was a form of of hell
not the fullness of it even the
description that you have the of the
trial you know that's right we're all in
Trials that's what yeah Jesus is led by
the spirit into the desert to be tested
by into a trial you know lead me not
into a trial leave me not to Temptation
deliver me from evil
so you come to
you your wife is there
one as a story end yes the story still
going on and she's freaked out like
basically like
she doesn't really know what to think
she's and you know my wife didn't grow
up in that world
so she doesn't see this she doesn't you
know she's just taking my word for it to
just like calm down relax it's gonna be
okay I pray whatever like
so she's just kind of like oh I'm glad
it's over I mean what do you really say
after that you know it's not like there
was a
a significant like reaction she was just
freaked out and she's like that was
scary you know and to this day like when
this thing comes up she's like yeah that
was scary you know and she'll say that
um
and then I laid in bed and I was scared
to move
you know for the rest of the night I
stayed awake saying hallelujah
hallelujah you know and for the next
three days I didn't want to talk I was
scared to talk I I mean that's what the
fear of God would I mean the fear of God
got so deeply drilled into me and not so
I'm scared of God the the acknowledgment
of his Holiness wonder and awe right
servile fear one yes is different than
holy the holy Sheriff exactly and so
that was the main takeaway from it like
God really is that that Holy and that
and that's so like that ties into this
whole you're your own God you're your
own Divine It's like because that's
that's what it well
all my friends who have gotten sucked
into this stuff uh whether we're talking
about chemical or just spiritual or
usually it's some kind of combination of
the two and it always seems to come down
to
you're your own God and you can do
whatever you want you've got the power
and you you you you and like if it's
about you you you you you're probably
not on the right path man yeah yeah I
agree I think that and that's
that's the uh I think
the the big like difference to me
is that God wants to create with us and
Jesus is the the the center of
everything
the whole this these whole other
movements they take everything that God
intended for us to have and and not
everything but some things and they just
kicked Jesus out of it so you know and
it reminds me of that Parable where the
the guys said I'm gonna send my helper
to the vineyard to get my fruit they
beat him up beat him up I'll send my son
they say oh we'll kill him so we can
inherit what belongs to him that's
literally what what Satan has done he's
he's perverted everything that God has
took it for himself and then made people
afraid of of certain things that God had
created for people and he kicked Jesus
out of it so it's like you know
everything's gotten perverted and it
looks the image of the Cross is the axle
on which the World Turns on which the
universe turns you know that's just
that's where it all turns around and
you can deny that but if you deny that
you're gonna find yourself
increasingly incoherent and you can you
can try to make a god of yourself that's
the Primal Temptation in the Garden of
Eden as you shall be as Gods but you're
not going to end up as a God you're
going to end up
destroyed physically and spiritually
absolutely absolutely not going to work
out no it's not it's not so yeah that's
I mean that's the and that's that that's
that yeah that's that story so Josh
it's an amazing story yeah yeah I was
going to say that's a hell of a story
but it's not a lot of it was a hell of a
story yeah but it's got a happy ending
ends like a comedy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it's good it doesn't at all
doesn't it all have happened I I hope
for most of us you know I think I think
it but I think that's what I gather yeah
the the the happy ending might not be
guaranteed well we're we're just talking
right now during Lent and that the
Easter exclamation that people make is
uh oh happy fault
in the Garden of Eden fall the sin that
destroyed protection oh happy fault the
one for us so great So Glorious a
redeemer that's what you're saying
Easter did you say oh um all right look
at that there was all this terrible
stuff that happened but God can turn
that even for good or good and uh and
then we all we have to do is cooperate
with God's grace see it should be this
easy part yeah yeah even time and time
again
five overdoses
yeah that's what I was saying though I I
I I I mean it's it's I know I'm just a
vessel of Mercy that's where that's the
point this has brought me to I know that
I'm only here because of God and God
Alone
uh you know I'm aware of that too you
know and so
now really the only thing I could do is
try to to just submit to his his will is
and his grace as much as I can you know
and
and stay on that that lane and so
thank you for coming in Josh of course
thank you for having me where can people
find you
um so I have an Instagram uh Joshua
underscore Kingdom priest
um and I have a tick tock the same thing
I have a YouTube Just My Name Joshua
Zach call
so I'm Michael Knowles we'll see you
next time
right here